what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
wall street
is trying to get rich the rest of us
trying to get a lunch money right
screw all of them uh i'm here plana's
here
nah i'm worked up today i got that
trillionaire energy going on can we take
it down billionaires that's fine
uh don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five pelina is
not happy at the moment she told me to
be chill this is me chill at the moment
pomp chill i blame myself because i got
him coffee that he didn't need
i haven't even drank it yet just wait
till i drink my super coffee i'll be
don't forget blockfi is now the sponsor
of lunch money go get a interest bearing
account you can earn up to eight point
six percent apy
in that interest rate account block five
dot com slash pomp block five dot com
slash pomp block five dot com slash pomp
let's roll
okay um game stop what the hell is going
on
shares traded at roughly 337 dollars per
share
when the stock had to be briefly halted
after 1 pm
up almost 128 from tuesday's
close the stock traded as high as three
hundred and eighty dollars per share
from six dollars let's go
you know why i love this no for two
reasons
one is counterintuitive citadel
is making all the money citadel is front
running
the robin hood trades and she yelled at
me damn
citadel is making all the money citadel
is front running all the trades on robin
hood which caused even more momentum
and then when melvin capital and all
these guys are like uh oh we might go
bankrupt like game over bk see ya
all of a sudden citadel steps in oh well
we have somebody we'll just buy some of
your firm as well
this is bonkers but the best part
that's one two
wall street is trying to turn the game
off
it's like when i used to whoop up on my
brother so bad in video games they'd be
upset and they would hit the power
button to shut it off before the game
ended because they were crying
because i was so much better than them
that's what's happening right now
is these wall street hedge funds are run
into the exchanges
and to the banks saying oh my god we're
losing so much money please stop the
trading of these stocks
please please please shut them off
sit in there and take your lumps you put
the trade on
you took the risk and you got short
squeezed
i hope they lose all their money that's
how the game
works gotta be kind to your friends
that's how the game works
because guess what if it was in reverse
and the wall street hedge fund
was screwing the little guy ain't nobody
gonna be saying
anything you know what would be
happening they'd be handing out bonuses
at the hedge fund
like it was candy they'd like a billion
for you 100 million for you 10 million
for you
no this year what's going on wall street
bets is
running things and i love it and by the
way
the reason why they're being successful
right now is because they've been able
to identify
market weaknesses right it's not like
they are doing anything other than they
found a weakness in the market
they're exploiting it and then other
hedge funds are realizing oh my god
these guys found a weakness
and they're going and they're riding the
momentum with them so at the end of the
day
this is how a market works is if you are
exposed
to additional risk then there is a
penalty for it but this whole idea we're
gonna stop trading up the stocks to
protect these guys
it's disgusting it is it's not american
open the markets leave the markets open
imagine if all of a sudden every time
that bitcoin's price started going down
i was like call i would call an exchange
like stop trading the bitcoin
stop trading the bitcoin we're losing
too much money
this is not wild that's not how a market
works okay i'm
literally cannot hear there's a guy on
youtube
with a 20 000 subscribers named roaring
kitty
and he sits in his freaking bedroom and
he's
literally got a spreadsheet and he's
running
circles around this hedge fund multiple
hedge funds
by the way guess what the hedge funds
they made plenty of money
they got billions of dollars they're
perfectly fine but if you take
risk you gotta stand in there and take
the heat when it goes wrong
the whole idea that you can somehow turn
the game off when you start losing
is garbage okay unions you have no
thoughts
well i i think you have enough thoughts
for everybody combined ever
but i just think it's crazy i i just
love i mean i don't love but i
i enjoy seeing how everybody's freaking
out like this has never happened
it's probably never happened before
right it's crazy
listen it reminds me of the french
revolution my favorite part of the whole
thing
by far is that other rich people
and other people in positions of power
and influence
are getting behind the wall street bets
guys why do you think that
this kind of like the people versus the
authorities and the powerful
is becoming so prevalent today
because this never went away like that's
the whole thing in 2008 2009 in zuccotti
park
when they were standing there screaming
occupy wall street
you know f the one percent that never
went away
people still believed that and so the
whole idea
that you could blow up the u.s economy
because you took so much risk
the joe blow at home he can't do that he
literally cannot do it
he can't even look he literally can't
get a mortgage
if he doesn't have a high enough credit
score but you clowns are out here giving
mortgages to anybody you want
blowing up the u.s economy that's the
feeling and so the same thing here
right is cool you literally can go
and you can lend a stock more
than there is how are you short over 100
it doesn't make any sense it's literally
just financial engineering
and so that's great you can financial
engineer you can financial engineer you
can financially engineer
all these profits it's awesome you have
the right to do that
but also if you're going to use the
right to do that stuff
then the people sitting at home on a
freaking
forum on a forum
are smarter than you really you since
you guys think you're so smart
then you should have to take the pain
for when you're wrong
that's it and so if you're going to do
all this nonsense
whoops caught you okay are you happy now
i hope they go due to more stocks oh my
gosh i do
okay okay okay and you want to know what
i bet happens
i bet you right now there's job offers
going out
job offers oh yeah i bet you a bunch of
these wall street hedge funds
are trying to get these guys in
consulting contracts trading jobs
whatever
because because they're seeing like
there's legit guys and they're doing
real work
now there's a bunch of other guys who
are like i saw one thing that said
we can remain basically stupid longer
than they can remain solvent
which is like pretty much the sentiment
but i do i do bet that there's people
reaching out to like whoever runs the
wall street bets
forum all that kind of stuff i'm trying
to get the chairman of my podcast
union square ventures said it will
invest that was very good
i'm very proud of you that's her that's
her talking down to me no problem i'm
not talking down
just like that just like the hedge funds
talk down to the wall street vets guys
the tyrannical leader that i live
under i'm the old guard here yeah
dictator
yeah we are moving on union square
she say no go ahead
union square adventure said it will
invest roughly 30 of its freshly minted
250 million dollars
from its 2021 core fund in crypto
related investments
as it has with other recent funds wow
usq yeah usb
what am i saying usq i'd be like trying
to short usb though
uh this is smart they've been at the
forefront of all of this
um i think that literally that group has
been
all over crypto for a while uh and i
love the fact that they are
uh going so far as to put a stake in the
ground and say look
you know very big fun we're gonna put a
very big percentage into
crypto should be a hundred percent but
tech investor chamath palipatia the
early facebook executive
and minority owner of the golden state
warriors basketball team
has thrown his hat in the ring for
running for california
governor if he seriously runs he wins
game over
book it right now over game
over okay but i feel like in california
a bunch of these tech guys have tried to
run before and it hasn't been that
favorable
i don't think any of them have tried not
that i know not like
legitimate you know big things uh
you know like big tech exacts his cam
his campaign proposals include a zero
percent state tax
a guaranteed seventy thousand dollar
salary for teachers
yes even higher make it a hundred and
providing two thousand dollars for every
newborn child
sorry new child born in california huh
oh my god it's like common sense ideas
wow amazing job
you're so smart duh right like and by
the way chamoth is really smart but he
literally knows that that stuff is
common sense
and he's like okay no one else can do
the common sense thing i'm gonna do it
which is exactly why he would win he's
got a big audience people respect him
he's made a bunch of money for himself
he'll help you make money and he's got
common sense policies
it's a shoe-in if he actually runs it's
kind of like my common sense platform
from new york city where i said my
platform is literally to put acs in the
subway stations
and nobody voted for i would vote for
you thank you yeah you'd have one vote
i'd still be a dictator one vote
no votes that was bait but i'm not
taking it okay
next sirius xm's latest satellite built
by
maxar and launched by spacex suffers
failure in
orbit oh no who's listening to the radio
oh no get on youtube
siriusxm yeah listen if you're in your
car
you don't need siriusxm you need lunch
money
that's what you need hold on we don't
have a podcast so how are they gonna
listen
pull it up on your phone play it through
the little aux cord
it's all right you do you know what i'm
scoring ready aux
um okay ready a u.s man
has installed a crypto mining rig in his
hybrid bmw sports car that's pretty dope
wow people going to turn their energy
into bitcoin so he's trying to turn the
gt into
the bitcoin yeah wow super cool using
uh all sorts of uh nvidia graphics cards
and things like that yeah
all right it's ask lunch money time
hashtag ask
ellen in the comments bang bang sorry
we're late today i've had a little i had
a hard day
pomp cryptojobs.com go to pomp
cryptojobs.com
pompcryptojobs.com that's what i was
doing all morning
okay get yourself a job levi carr very
interesting question
what is the most seemingly happenstance
random situation in your life
that led you in a new direction or
changed your future the most
for me it's my parents winning the green
card lottery
in bulgaria in 1999 it is the reason i
am here today
it's a lottery it's barely your chance
of
of the applicants that apply every year
your chance of winning on
any given year is 0.001 or something
it's harder than harvard uh reading rich
dad poor dad
by far really well i read that rich said
uh the richest man in babylon and
thinking girl russia i had those three
books all at the same time when i was
sitting in the desert in iraq at 20
years old
uh and completely changed my life um
also a comment from
brevit howe guys plant-based
drinks it's called juice fast that that
is true
i i read this comment and i was like man
we need a correspondent on the show
because that is a fact
because we were like idiots yesterday
like what does plant-based drinks mean i
think there is something else that's not
juice but that was a good one
um hi lm team
thanks for the knowledge you guys are
spreading question for you both for
someone who's just starting out their
own podcast newsletter or blog
what's the best piece of advice you can
give them and how do you guys manage to
put out so much
content and so keep it extremely high
quality i have one
very big piece of advice consistency
plus time
equals trust so if you're going to start
a podcast or a newsletter or a blog
stick to a cadence that you can
regularly publish on
so if it's every week make sure you're
putting it out every week because over a
long period of time
that's how your audience and your
readers or consumers will
trust you i agree with that consistency
basically don't even start you shouldn't
start it's hard you have to bang your
head against the wall for like five
years don't do it
i've been doing it since 2017 and look
how old i look
18 i've been doing it since 17. no i was
doing this since 2017 18
no 2017 i got on the tweeter the tweeter
oh you mean twit i thought you meant
your newsletter oh the newsletter
that's fine but yeah but seriously it
takes years and so if you're not willing
to hit
it every single day week month whatever
your cadence is
for years then just don't start and by
the way if i just convinced you not to
start
then you weren't going to do it anyway
so i just saved you a bunch of time send
me some bitcoin we'll call it even
all right no by the way there's a lot of
trolls
and scammers in the comments do not
uh text that whatsapp number or contact
anybody he will never ask you for
bitcoin
he'll never want your money or ask you
to text anybody that's not
and the scams are elaborate like i've
seen literally like fake contracts fake
business cards all this stuff don't get
scammed
if you ain't see my ugly face on zoom
do not send money okay that's all i have
see you hey wall street bets
anthony bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends